[موسيقى]
وعرف علي
الموقع او المنصب شعرت بانني محظوظ يعني
وبالتالي
ذهبت بنوع من انواع الحماس ولكن ارهانات
رهانات محدده لان الفرص وهذا ما ذكرته
عليه باستمرار الفرصه ليست سعيده او شقيه
الا بحسب ما تحولها انت الى رهان وتحاول
ان تكسره وبالتالي سافرت
في ذهني انه انا اعرف شكل رئيس المعهد من
فتره طويله وذكرت التفاصيل هذه المعرفه
وكنت اتوقع انه الموضوع الي او بشكل او
باخر يعني سهل جدا
وحينما
التقيتم مره مره اخرى ادركت ادركت انه كان
يخفي غير غير ما يظهر لانه المملكه
للامانه اخذت
حصتها من المنصب مع الاستاذ مناخ زندار
بقيه سنه او فتره ونصف يعني حوالي اربع
سنوات ونص وبالتالي المملكه كانت قانونيا
ليس ليس لها سوى سنه ونصف
انا راح انت على انه سنه ونص لا يمكن اقبل
المنصب واتفقنا على ثلاث سنوات لكن اكتشفت
انه حتى هذا التنازل لم يكن
لم يكن مقنعا له وبالتالي شعرت انه يلعب
لعبه معينه لعبه مكر فقلت لابد ان ناتي من
فوق يعني عند لابد يكون في مكه وبدات اكشف
الاوراق للسفر
[موسيقى]
هذه انه كان لديه مرشح عربي اخر وانه كان
فيه وعد من الملك عبد الله رحمه الله
بمبلغ معين دعم المعهد قبل قبل وقبل اظن
المناخه حتى وكان يريد ان يحصل عليه ويقول
انتم قانونين اخذتم حصتكم وانتهى الموضوع
فحين معرضت الموضوع على
المعادن الاستاذ خالد العنقري وهو يعني من
هو في الخبره والتجربه ولكن ايضا كان في
نوع من انواع العلاقه الحميمه انا اقول
الصداقه لكن علاقه حميمه بيني وبينه من
فتره معينه
فيبدو انه حسمها بطريقه
جيده
وغريب جدا انه بعد ما مر ثلاث سنوات اصر
رجع كلانق
قبل غيره على ان يمدد لي ثم مد جلي وفي
الفتره الثانيه قبيل سفري باسابيع وفي يوم
واحد كان يرسل لي كل مره شخص لكي امدد
الفتره الثالثه
[موسيقى]